mais ça incroyable mais c'est vrai en
cette histoire est vraie moi j'étais fan
absolu de jean luc delarue
vraiment et oui oui m'a reçu 2,3 fois
dans ses émissions des voix le thème 2e
saut je l'enlève
alors vraiment vraiment d'abord il
reçoit super bien il était adorable sur
moi je m'en rends pas compte quand les
gens prennent des choses ou pas il a été
parfait l'interview s'est divinement
passé sur le plateau il a été gentil
avec tout le monde il a été adorable bon
ça moi j'étais très surpris par toutes
ces révélations parce qu'en tant la
fréquenter comme moi quand même même
temps lui-même le restaurant qu'il avait
ouvert à l'époque c'était en bas de chez
moi le nobu à une époque tu sais avec
robert de niro et il est désirable bob
de niro de niro robert de niro robert de
niro généraux de de niro adacore
qu'est-ce que j'ai d'ailleurs robert de
niro alors maire de nice a été limé donc
si vous voulez il était toujours
impeccable moi je me suis rencontre
rendue compte de rien et pour moi
c'était une grande surprise d'apprendre
tout ça
moi je n'ai pas connu du tout eric de la
ruche est juste une petite anecdote avec
lui et moi il m'a reçu un jour dans son
émission dont ça se discute c'était fort
voilà geste et il m'a déçu parce que
j'avais la phobie des figues
thématiques
vous avez une question qui était très
bien montré dans le reportage c'est que
des gens essaient m'était très bien
monter dans leur portée en sketches qui
étaient très bien entrés dans leur corps
était que beaucoup de gens ont essayé
mais n'ont pas pu l'empêcher de prendre
de la drogue est ce que vous vous avez
essayé d'arrêter ses dérivés ce qu'on
pouvait lui dire écoute arrête tu vas te
détruire gâcher son talent non personne
ne pouvait ou ne pouvait pas non c'est
impossible alors que jean-luc qui
faisait ce qu'il voulait quand il
voulait et pourtant elle avait une garde
rapprochée mais il y avait personne pour
pouvoir lui dire alors c'était des
sous-entendus mais personne n'ose et
jean-luc il était quand même c'était
quelqu'un qui avait énormément de
prestance et c'est avec les gens avec
quand même difficilement on la
profession l'approché difficilement les
gens avaient peur de lui très peu de
personnes finalement obtenu était
pendant toutes ces années mais non
c'était impossible
faire quoi que ce soit ça sans casque
moi j'ai failli battre avec avec
jean-luc gelé connu l'époque où il
produisait flavie flament dans star de
mariemont nex nex est en fait et quand
je l'aï vu la première fois de faire ses
missions je trouve excellent producteur
incroyable et donc moi j'avais dit à m6
à l'époque et je voudrais à mon travail
avec eux avec ce gain et puis finalement
j'ai revu après j'ai trouvé comme est
effectivement assez bizarre et je
trouvais ça très compliqué travaille
avec lui parce que la deuxième mission
était vraiment totalement dans un état
second il ne l'est pas que ça enfin
comme ça c'était assez assez triste et
j'ai dit à la chaîne finalement je peux
plus travailler avec avec jean-luc et
j'étais convoqué à l'époque au corps va
quitter son aileron mobile fait du code
du coup de vent et le coca et itochu je
me suis arrivé à l'heure je me suis
assis à une table il est arrivé d'aller
moi et me dit m'a dit ça c'est ma place
tu bouges âge et ça commence bien là le
rendez vous donc gg mais c'était
quelqu'un
est juste on était un peu en mode en
mode génère il m'a dit alors qu'il est
quel problème parce que nous on émeutes
à on est des loups et les brebis on va
les bouffer c'est comme à l'époque
j'étais un peu toniques bac s qui avait
cessée quoi c'est quoi le problème
gestion au sort tu vas garder tes gardes
du corps je gardais des miens je vois
tout sur nagl est vraiment on était à
deux doigts de sortir pour les soutes
sur la gueule ce qui n'est
finalement ça c'est au cep à taper
dessus et il avait des briquets
réservoir 38 est très beau et à la fin
du repas je lui dis bon bah voilà sans
rancune pourquoi est-ce que je prends le
petit boîtier m'a dit non ce week-end à
ça se mérite
moi je comprends tout à fait
d'autant que benjamin excusez moi mais à
la question la télé fait elle pété les
plombs vous êtes un bon exemple vous
avez nommé vous est adorable mais vous
avez pété les plombs avec des bras comme
ça ils font comme ça toujours dans la
durcir y casser la gueule alors
sa part j'ai vraiment dû le fermer mais
non mais non mr actualiser des sept
jurés que j'aurais voulu que ça l'a
toujours été très courtois il est
courtois jamais
bien parce que j'avais vu un jour avec
un blouson en cuir ouais ça leur demande
pourquoi éligibles jour avec un blouson
en cuir atterrit mais bien donc il m'a
pris en jeu ici je vais le trac je
l'attrapé landais
à ta question sur la caricature et je
les dis avant-hier angie c'est le plus
gentilhomme à faire ce métier animateur
vedette est vraiment dans l'est dans le
top 10 personnes peut le faire en étant
normal et on est au tout ça normal enfin
à lambeau série dead n'est pas normal je
ne suis pas normal il n'est pas normal
bien fait normal que vous et moi je
trouve que benjamin je trouve qu'il a
vraiment garder les pieds sur terre il a
il a kiffé avec pendant un moment il a
gagné énormément d'argent il sert
kieffer moi j'avais dit c'est pas un mec
qui pète un câble c'est juste limpide
les skippers
jeudi chez escher c'est guillaume ce
matin puisqu'il est fait tomber son
petit mot redouterait sa voix son groupe
et je pense qu'on a tous quand on est
animateur on a tous des des faiblesses
des failles qui fut arrêté là on se
construit pourquoi est-ce qu'un mec
comme drucker à 91 ans ne s'arrête pas
c'est que quelque part il n'est pas
n'est pas normal pourquoi est ce qu'ils
continuent encore et encore et pourrait
s'arrêter un croyant qu'il fait mais
quelque part sendra grèce et quelque
part c'est anormal le seul que je compte
que je pense qu'il est vraiment normal
c'est fou comme les gens bien sûr j'en
de stabilité et que sa famille sa
maisterra et nous autres on est tous
patronat je suis non
je vous expliquais qui vous êtes vous
c'est mon choix est ce que votre
construction est allé bouffer vraiment
la tartine de kaka
vous avez mangé pendant 15 ans la
tartine de merde de merde par petits
bouts et vous avez réussi 15 ans après
et ce qui est génial c'est que vous êtes
devenu le cyrano du paf le edmond dantès
vous êtes revenue en engrangeant mais
sainement soif de réussite et c'est ce
qui vous a que je pense équilibré moi je
me suis dit si je mange équilibré mais
vrai très équilibré et je pense que
cette façon là cette façon d'être d'être
nonchalant charme des monts a revanche
non mais j'ai écouté ce que je dis c'est
assez c'est ce qu'ils n'ont pas d'être
revanchard mais dans la revanche ça vous
a effectivement utilisé ça nous a
construit moi je voulais que mes parents
soient fiers de moi il englobe moi ça
j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
mais moi c'était important et que je
n'ai pas vraiment entendu il a fallu que
je démontre à ma famille à ma mère que
jamais du poignet ou ceux qui vous
répondent stupide mais la raison c'est
que tout dépend ce que la télé vient
combler exactement si la connaît bien
combler une faille qui de toute façon ne
pourra jamais être réparé vous allez
pété les plombs donc j'ai travaillé les
réponses que j'ai treize écuries dont
s'est entouré etc ça va peut-être
l'aider guérir et puis ça vous allez
trouver une forme de stabilité c'est
tout dépend de ça alors je voulais en
fait comment j'ai une fois au téléphone
jean luc blanc rien la dernière en 2010
avant qu'il eut passé je les rencontre
est aussi au globe de cristal et il
m'avait dit je leur serai chez moi je
l'adoré et il m'avait dit tu vas voir il
m'a dit tu vas être le très très grand
animateur de la havane il m'a dit j'ai
les manifs je pense que tu vas être un
il m'a dit j'ai eu je te regarde et je
te regarder tout ça parce que je faisais
france 4 le soir à l'époque je croyais
que j'avais démarré en 2010 france 4 et
regarder et me disait tu vas voir ça va
être ça va être énorme mais moi j'avais
dit que je le kiffe et christophe toi
c'est là des anecdotes de fou avec
jean-luc de langues ah ouais j'en ai une
langue d'articuler un jour martin son
assistante m'appelle et me dit écoute
christophe son chauffeur est tombé
malade il faut que tu le remplace je dis
bah écoute pas tout si moi j'étais
content je distribue le courrier donc je
mets diva c'est cool je vais de
chauffeur de jean luc delarue donc
j'étais jeune j'avais une vingtaine
d'années et puis elle me dit écoute
voilà je tire à le récupérer demain
matin à 9h parce qu'elle a rendez vous à
10h avec jérôme seydoux chez pathé et le
rendez-vous ne peut pas le rater c'est
le patron de pathé un jour de chez pathé
et
du coup on donne l'adresse tout ça et où
elle me dit c'est pas chez lui il est
chez hubert boukobza en fait dans un
hôtel particulier que dans le 16e et
donc du coup j'arrive avec la voiture là
bas je sonne ça me répond en personne ne
me répond et tout et puis au bout de
cinq minutes un portail s'ouvre là je me
retrouve dans une maison incroyable moi
j'ai jamais vu ça de mammifères je
commence possible une maison aussi grand
avec un jardin en plein en plein coeur
de paris est tout et puis je rentre dans
cette maison et puis là je vois que
maeva migros fait qui a été fait
et là vous voyez daniel mots
[Applaudissements]
avec un string faut
donc là et en fait j'ai un costume dans
les mains et c'est la maison les grandes
banques je venais où est ce que je vais
pouvoir trouver jean luc et là il ya une
demoiselle qui sort d'une pièce je
discutais moi c'est pas que je peux
retrouver ceux de la wii à médine
chambre rouge thurgovie chambre rouge
moi je commence à monter à l'étagé là
pour change joue encore rouge donc je
commence à frapper et où personne ne me
répond j'appelle assistant les ja martin
écoute je suis d'ailleurs une porte elle
est rouge et le costume qu'est ce que je
fais me dire entre
j'ouvre la porte et là effectivement je
vois jean du qui dormait depuis qu'est
ce que je fais un petit réveil le clash
media for moi je viens d'arriver chez
réservoir prod ya six mois je suis avec
un costume dans les mains je dois rey et
jean luc delarue je suis dit mais
j'étais sûr oui oui bon ok je mets je
m'approche de lui je commence un petit
peu à le secouer gentiment et où je
m'aperçois que non il dort bien quoi et
je lui dis je fais quoi me dise coup le
jeu commence à le secouer n'avait pas
fait comme moi comme quand j'aurai mais
qui
aurait pu et du coup se réveille alors
ya donc là il m'appelle par tous les
prénoms sauf par par le mien je suis dit
jean-luc je te pose ton costume sur le
lit je t'attends bah moi qu'il arrive au
bout de dix minutes par en voiture et
m'ont pas la voiture il dit par amo et
tous ont par contre je dépose je le
dépose chez pathé et là je me plante
c'est à dire quoi au lieu de le déposer
à l'entrée principale je dépose sur ne
portent pas peut dérober tout mais du
coup très ce mois là et on se voit tout
à l'heure chez réservoir prod est là je
me dis moi c'est fini pour moi forcément
je les vis dans un état que j'aurais pas
dû
et là je me dis moi tu sais quoi et dans
une belle voiture kif là je prends tout
mon temps pour entrer à gaza reprennent
ce que là j'ai fais pas je suis à la
deauville
et du coup j'arrive à un réservoir et et
il lui arrive de trois heures après et
me convoque dans son bureau et hellemmes
du coup de christophe voilà qu'est ce
que tu aimerais faire chez moi et je
distribue le courrier et judy khutba
avoir une tête des ambitions et où je
tue bah ouais je dis j aurais bien
travaillé au public claire le public c
ap les gens pour qu'ils viennent sur le
plateau est tout et mehdi ben écoute tu
commence demain matin
en fait ça a été un enchaînement pomme
ça de choses et c'est pour ça je voulais
aussi le remercier parce motion c'est un
garçon quatre cas qui donnait qui
donnait sa chance aux jeunes moi je suis
arrivé de nulle part justin milo que je
connaissais pas et finalement j'ai
réussi à dire avec voilages en lutte et
puis ses équipes autour de 2 grammes et
gestion et puis
benjamin bailly il a quand même raté je
pense le plus gros contrat de sa vie
avec tf1 puisqu'il devait de signer au
mip ben si tu connaissais tous points de
vue c'est le grand salon d'audiovisuel
et en fait il y avait une fête la veille
encore une fête et il est arrivé au
petit déjeuner le matin visiblement dans
un état un peu normal un peu fatigué il
est parti avec le buffet du petit
déjeuner donc ça s'est su qu'ils
n'étaient pas forcément en forme et
l'avion de boeing était en train de deux
femmes étaient partis pour aller signer
le contrat avec à l'époque le directeur
finances cost et edouard boccon-gibod
que tu as connu qui étaient bloquées et
en fait on la formation est revenue aux
oreilles de le lait que visiblement
l'animateur qu'il allait engager pour un
énorme contrat avait une grosse tendance
à prendre des produits stupéfiants et
comme l'est et le présidente est
fréquent mais comme et comme patrick le
lay monsieur le lay avait vécu un drame
personnel à cause de la drogue par
rapport à ces à ses enfants pour lui la
drogue c'était rédhibitoire il a fait
faire demi-tour à l'avion et le contrat
s'est jamais signé tout ça parce que là
bas il avait fait mais je pense qu'il
doit voir ma là il avait pas de limites
il s'en foutait il dit lors il y aurait
donc plus gros que la vie avec ça et
toujours plus loin toujours plus fort my
baby girl
rigueur la télé patron d'orange et il
était très riche ou pas joué non
honnêtement non c'est pas par hâtivement
à d'autres noms ont franchement ça
on va pas se mentir non mais il a en
fait et georges en lui qui a fait des
très mauvaises affaires des restos il a
il a englouti près de 50 millions sa
société était devenu une espèce d'énorme
boîte où il y avait près de 600
collaborateurs qui étaient ni sous
redressement judiciaire ils ont dû faire
un plan et c'est alors qu'il a perdu
encore beaucoup d'argent il a laissé
mais dont on ne parle de 22 millions
c'est ça un appartement sur les quais de
paris il ya eu des maisons à bellilois
l'île de ré il ya un réservoir fois qui
a été vendu au groupe lagardère pour 10
millions d'euros je crois à l'époque
donc c'est passé c'est beaucoup d'argent
mais constantine mais comparativement à
ce qu il a à ce qu'il a brassé ce qu'il
a générée c'est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup moins que beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'autres d'accord voilà
ma bulle d'air voilà il ait pas de
bateau les pas de 4,4
[Applaudissements]
je stoppe c'est vrai que c'était un thé
une vie incroyable jean luc delas parce
qu'aujourd'hui jean luc delarue c'est
quoi c'est un peu le lait l'équivalent
en quoi c'est une amie ces voix là
aujourd'hui c'est quoi ces c'est vrai
ces annonces et annoncé pas non non ce
serait plus vous vraiment moi je ne bois
que de l'eau à quelques
noms mais c'est vrai qu'il n'en
resterait que on n'a pas du tout le même
fonctionnement c'est vrai qu'il ya pas
mal de gens qui m'ont dit plein de fois
aussi je vous jure que c'est vrai qu'ils
m'ont dit c'est vrai que tu nous fait
penser à jean luc delarue oui mais c'est
vrai que j'ai jade et moi j'adorais
janvier que j'étais fan absolu mais
c'est vrai que moi on n'a pas du tout le
même temps que ce nombre c'est vrai que
je suis je suis naturellement à tchité
en fait et c'est vrai que c'est à dire
que la différence entre du jean luc
delarue moi c'est que jean-luc il
arriver à l'antenne il se transforme et
moi c'est vrai que je suis le même temps
sur le plateau n'était pas agiter en
fait tiendra paradoxal on n'était pas
des plus tôt abrutis et
sommet est assommée par tous qui prônait
en alcool et la vérité c'est que jean
luc delarue avant même de commencer à
faire de la tf vraiment une star était
déjà dans une addiction à l'alcool et
aux médicaments donc en fait c'est
énorme réussite qu'il a eu comme tu l'as
dit n'a fait que l'amplifier une fin qui
était qui était déjà bien bien présente
mais ce qui est rouge que je trouve
assez étonnant c'est que 1 et ça vous
n'avez pas tellement des dans vos coeurs
dock mais ce qui est dommage pour lui
c'est qu'il était beaucoup protégé et
que si on n'avait pas autant protégé mon
à une époque peut-être qu'il aurait pu
arrêter ces commentaires mais c'est
parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup de prises co2
de son affaire voilà qu'ils ont et son
entourage et son entourage étaient pas
forcément le meilleur voilà et ce alors
il ya une scène dont on a parlé ccsl au
globe de cristal ces vandales à revoir
et bernard va nous donner les coulisses
mais j'étais jeune il était là il
connaît les coulisses bernard il connaît
les coulisses de tout bois non mais
c'est vrai non mais
-
ah c'est l'année des femmes bien me
languis yamina
trop cher de cristal sa pelouse et la
[Applaudissements]
félicitation
[Musique]
ouais ouais ouais mais justement ouais
c'est à dire que lui
parce que moi une bonne loi
il va mieux ça ne sert personne et c'est
vrai que cette histoire et ça fait assez
moi j'adore yamina en plus qui n'a
missiles amis à vous aussi on l'adoré ça
l'a choquée elle ou pas du tout sur le
coup on n'entendait pas ce qu'on disait
pas entendu elle n'a pas vu tout ce
qu'il a dit ce qu'il a dit tiens je vais
tenir vos globes parce qu'elle a eu à
notre prix via notre globe de cristal
pour un autre documentaire donc elle est
arrivée sur scène elle n'a pas réalisé
et il faisait le clown derrière c'est
moi j'étais à la table de france 3 est
la tablette de yamina d'ailleurs yamina
qui revient à table on dit tu as entendu
ce qu'il a dit sur toi et même le patron
de france 3 de ce monde a dit je suis
désolée accepter nos excuses et elle a
dit mais je sais pas qu'est ce qu'il a
dit on n'entendait rien sur scène en
fait il lui a dit je vais vous tenir vos
globes bribon voilà donc bon yamina elle
était un peu choqués d'ailleurs lui
envoya un énorme bouquet de fleurs bien
sûr il ce qui est intéressant c'est que
ce soir là directement le patron me dit
c'est même une directrice elle me dit
berlin est ce que vous êtes prêt à le
remplacer immédiatement parce que là on
peut pas supporter tous que si ça
continue comme ça on ne peut pas
supporter en fait ils avaient déconné
toute la soirée alors qu'il reste et
élégant à part ça il est resté les gants
correct et drôle et je suis un mec
brillant et là il voulait vraiment le
dégager en pleine cérémonie c'est fou et
m'ont demandé de le remplacer ce que
j'ai refusé bien sûr bien sûr moteur
raison tu peux pas faire ça va pas faire
sa sélection toi tu es un petit peu
totem de cet été comme totti comme en
équipe de france je m'étais sur le bon
tu peux remplacer
auprès du numéro 12 e bernard montiel
sortie du numéro 14
je peux remplacer ça parce qu'il peut il
à tous les talons et peut tout faire oui
c'est vrai mais j'ai pas voulu le faire
et d'ailleurs après cette séquence il a
été interdit de direct n'a plus jamais
fait des missions et y maintient
télévision et franchement on en a trop
fait parce que c'était sur france 3
nador était dans une émission de
divertissement sur france 2 ou tf1 se
serait passé michael il ya une séquence
de jean luc delarue qui regardent la
séquence qui franchement j'ai pas abuser
et je trouve qu'on en a trop fait sur
cette séquence qui il dit ça va graver
alors la séquence très très forte vous
voulez vous montrer c'est cette séquence
avec son papa son père qui est juste
cruel d'avoir été isolé de son fils
regardez pas qui est autour de lui quand
il est mort
et bien toujours pas sa famille de sang
donc qu'il y avait bien sûr les veuves
épices et soeurs et puis frère voilà
donc la famille algérienne on avait pris
le contrôle de jean luc on avait éloigné
tous ceux qui étaient proches de lui et
par ailleurs il y avait aussi des
éditions à son testament qui était
présente
donc on a fait ce qu'on puisse qui ont
fait régulièrement ce cas là c'est à
dire pour eux on va gagner beaucoup
d'argent on isole la personne 14 femmes
qui skient atroce c'est d'avoir fait
croire aujourd'hui que sa famille ne
voulait plus voir empêcher sa mère ou
son père de voir son garçon avant qui
meurt c'est quand même
essentiel est vraiment l'empêcher c'est
parce que manque cruel là c'est beau
hein c'est honteux parce que en fait il
voulait plus voir son père du tout son
père est extrêmement dur avec lui
extrêmement violent extrêmement
intéressé extrêmement méchants arrivent
c'est choquant d'entendre ça parce que
c'est pas du tout c'est lui qui a des
cheveux justement de rompre avec sa
famille parce qu'ils n'aillent plein
d'eau et c'est pas du tout cette anissa
qu'il a détourné de qui que ce soit mais
tu as intelligent et sardon c'est white
and
we could est ce que dit le père il dit
que jean luc delarue était complètement
sous influence quelques mois avant sa
mort cali ça lui aurait demandé de se
convertir à l'islam donc le père dit que
jean luc delarue est mort en étant
musulman elles auraient pris le contrôle
de son téléphone donc et quelques jours
quelques semaines avant sa mort le père
de jean luc delarue pensée échangé des
sms avec son fils mais selon lui en
réalité c'était anissa où la famille
d'annie salaires le téléphone je donne
t'il alors qu'il l'aurait empêchée
d'avoir des contacts avec lui depuis son
fils était sous influence avant de
mourir se réfère à l'héritage parce que
ça a été très compliqué après mais c'est
vrai que les relations interpersonnelles
entre eux était hyper compliqué hyper
conflictuelle presque violente depuis
des années il ya eu un grand rôle du
père et jean luc delarue se sentait lui
même en quelque sorte abandonnées par ce
père et non aidées par ce père m'a
manqué à ce que la télé peut faire péter
les plombs ça dépend comment vous vivez
si vous voulez vous allez pète un plomb
à écouter sincèrement jamais c'est vrai
même 38 ans que tu as la télévision bon
j'ai jamais été non plus d'un des grands
des mystery c'est vidéo gag la famille
en or et de foot les grands shows du
samu oui
non ça dépend comment vous vivez et
c'est quand même moi l'intérêt c'est
évident de rentrer chez moi c'était
moyen c'est surtout ce qu'on disait
d'ailleurs avec benji c'est qu'avant
j'ai eu des métiers beaucoup plus dur
que la terrifier j'étais justice et
c'était viola rock et écoliers à titre
personnel par la call girl afin
[Rires]
d'aider mais en fait j'avais des métiers
beaucoup plus violent à van est qui qui
à titre personnel mais handicapé et me
péter la tête c'est alors là le fait
d'arriver à la télé c'est calme dans
l'extraction de la lumière on reçoit des
artistes etc
là ça me va ça me correspond tout à fait
mais il est vrai que d'avoir fait un
métier aussi difficile la banque comme
missié ça m'a permis d'avoir les pieds
sur terre et est toujours maintenant ça
vous intéresse pas ce qui bien sûr
benjamin todd toi tu as le sentiment
d'avoir pété les plombs ben non moi je
me suis suicider par l'argent je suis
cité par l'argent et je rêvais étouffé
avec
décidée j'aurais pu sombrer dans la
nacam l'alcool jamais j'avais le choix
est en fête finalement c'est je pense
que c'était le syndrome du bras trop
court ah oui c'est ça le fait moyen en
fait c'est que c'est quand vous n'êtes
pas trop court quand vous êtes dans une
dynamique où vous voulez toujours trouvé
des choses aux autres quand vous tendez
le break vous avez atteint quelque chose
pour aider parce que vous avez atteint
mais vous regardez ce qui après à wes
qu'on appelle e52 s'interdit droits trop
courts donc aimé dans mon cas c'était le
vrae et voilà mais maintenue mais après
moi je me souviens très bien j'étais
capable de 2 2 me après après avoir
faire bon repas d'ailleurs je vais
m'acheter une voiture toi quel syndrome
de l'accoutrement
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
dur parce que ça te fait peur tout ça
bah oui moi je pense que l'autorité ça
rend con mais ça rend les autres qu'on
aussi et moi c'est toi c'est vrai que tu
as peut-être un peu le look jean luc
delarue ont fait un plus petit quoi
jean-luc de l'impasse
si les gens font et moi je suis toujours
choqué de voir par exemple d'aider des
gens qui sont prêts à tout pour
s'approcher de personnes célèbres de
coucher avec des personnes célèbres un
restaurant à personne dérange moins ça
ça me choque un resto à paris par an
vous tous les soirs il ya des
footballeurs des chanteurs des rappeurs
etc et des nanas d'or jeudi soir pour
non mais c'est les voilà moi c'est grâce
à des gens qui sont prêts est souvent
sénat voilà pour pour coucher avec ces
gens là et je trouve que ça peut rendre
fou et ça rend les autres qu'on aussi
non plus avec les autres et j'ai une
anecdote sur un film je travaillais avec
john cusack sort un film évoque les
acquis de chaque couleur de jean luc
delarue
ce que tu attendais pas mieux que de
s'intégrer au reste du casting etc mais
il y avait constamment tous ces agents
sont publics etc qui le tenait alors le
faisait avoir une chaise spéciale un
stand spécial chronique c'est moi on
dirait que vous aussi que je vous parle
pas voilà l'embellie gilles regarder
pressé l'entourage en plus
souvent on pose la question de savoir si
c'est la personne qui change mais en
fait c'était tout ce qui se passe autour
y compris la façon dont on s'adresse à
la passe que vous avez changé où je
crois pas est ce que tu veux trouver que
moi qu'on cause d'une entorse contrôle
des changes et la noyade toujours c'est
un changement
franchement non mais franchement c'est
juste que vous êtes encore plus tard est
tombé en orbite oui voilà en fait vous
avez une chance c'est que d'abord vous
êtes très entouré ce que vous avez une
famille à papa une maman qui sont
proches de vous et qui sont importants
pour vous vos enfants vous tire aussi
vers la vraie vie et c'est ça qui fait
que aussi en bon voilà et puis de 2,2
trois copains qui vous disent des trucs
mais mais il faut qu'il faut toujours et
vous vous avez vous fait quelque chose
d' extrêmement intelligent vous avez
gardez vos copains d'enfance et souvent
parfois les copains d'enfance et
disparaissent champion et ses g copains
d'enfance qui ose dire parce qu'ils
connaissent pas le truc qu'ils y voient
le problème c'est et abidal avait donc
pâti
tu déconne mais mais sinon ce qui arrive
au coeur d'un banc dans le fou il faudra
déjà interdits sont bien sûr les
garde-fous quoi oui il affirmé oui
depuis avant en fait on fait des
parallèles entre votre succès et celui
de jean luc delarue et avec tout ça mais
ce qui est fou c'est que vous vous êtes
sain en fait vous êtes si vous êtes
vraiment comme ça mais tout le monde se
fait des fantasmes sur vous la france
entière se dit c'est pas possible
combien de chasse en s'amenant mais
cyril hanouna match et en fait non vous
êtes ça c'est juste du coca peut-être
bon c'est ça l'oasis le mid à part ça et
je trouve ça fantastique
bravo parce que vous c'est vous est ce
que les gens font ça en substance
christophe qui me connaît bien c'est un
potage l'adorent christophe c'est vrai
que franchement de reset agitée oui
c'est ça je fais jti séquence télésérie
les biens pendant le même depuis 20 ans
quand ma mère est agité mon père est
architecte
voulez que je fasse voilà sept moines
sont agités les enfants sont agités et
la famille est agité les étoiles voilà
oui décision sur un plateau sans jamais
de toilette pas le cas des animateurs
c'est vrai que je fais pipi jamais
jamais jamais jamais jamais ça chez
google oui bah moi je viens d'arriver
faut quand même dire que la télé rend un
peu fou les gens dans les gens qui nous
regardent la doivent se dire son culotté
de traiter ce sujet sur ce plateau là
vous êtes quand même tous fous
la raison hier j'ai regardé l'émission
hier et un moment tu pouvais quand même
voir un avocat spécialisé en vaccins et
en placements de produits s'embrouiller
avec un nez aux sénégalais jeunes mariés
de 58 ans
[Applaudissements]
on en parlait dernière fois elle valérie
et on se disait en fait le syndrome c
est ce que tous ils étaient fous et toi
tu as rassemblé des foules où est-ce qu'
il s' étaient normaux et deux mois dans
six mois je vais me réveiller en mode à
un extraterrestre
laquelle je pense que tu vas te
réveiller dormait pas dans six mois
serait ce pas six mois